هي جريمه تسجل وتضاف الى جرائم الاحتلال
باقتحام صرح طبي اقتحام اروقه مستشفى
اقتحام اقسام المستشفى غرف المستشفى
واغتيال داخل المستشفى هذه جريمه يعني
تضاف الى سجل جرائم الاحتلال والاعتداء
على طاقم الطبي ايضا هذه جريمه
يعني يجب الوقوف عندها ومحاسبه الاحتلال
على هذه الجرائم وبكل تاكيد احن بناكد على
بيان معالي وزيره صحه وهو التوجه وبلغه
شديده الى الجهات الدوليه الى المنظمات
الدوليه لحقوق الانسان حقوق المواطنين
منظمه الصحه العالميه بضروره الوقوف عند
مسؤولياتهم وتحمل مسؤولياتهم
و محاسبه الاحتلال على هذه الجرائم عندما
يتم اغتيال مواطنين داخل اروقه المستشفى
داخل غرف المستشفى يتم اغتيال مرضى داخل
مستشفى وهنالك شخص من احد الذين تم
اغتيالهم هو احد المرضى في هذه الم مستشفى
ومع مرافقيه وبكل تاكيد هذا المريض كان
يعالج منذ اشهر في المستشفى وفي
قسم التاهيل الطبي وكلكم بتعرفوا التاهيل
الطبي بكل تاكيد لا يستطيع المريض لا
يستطيع ان يخدم نفسه بنفسه فبالتالي هو
بحاجه لان يكون هنالك مرافقين وتم اختيال
المريض والمرافقين مع هذا المريض وكل
تاكيد هذه جريمه يعني نخشى ما نخشاه ان
تكون هي سياسه جديده
ا